[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es einen super einfaches
rezept und zwar mache ich mal wolf
cupcakes und die maulwurf cupcakes sind
dekoriert mit kleinen märchen und ich
weiß nicht warum ich finde es passt
irgendwie zu ostern oder hase möglichen
poster haben ostern und zu weihnachten
genauso rasch verstanden oder aber
carrot cake passt ja auch immer
und ja jetzt habe ich hier eine einfache
idee mit cupcakes die kammer in teilen
und auch verschenken die kann man auch
mal ganz schön mit ihm auch nicht
richtig gemacht habe ich nur als genau
als muffins und wir sind echt super
einfach gebraucht keine besonderen
gegenstände keine küchenmaschine und sie
sind auch sehr schnell gemacht und ich
fange jetzt mal mit muffins tag an und
zeige euch hier für die zutaten für den
martinstag nämlich 150 gramm zucker eine
prise salz 160 gramm mehl 40 gramm
kakaopulver inhalten teelöffel
backpulver und einen viertel teelöffel
natron zweier 200 milliliter buttermilch
oder normale mint und 150 gramm flüssige
butter für den martinstag nehme ich
jetzt zuerst trockenen zutaten und sie
führe ich jetzt in der schüssel also
zucker salz mehl backpulver nato und
kakao wenn ihr kein natron habt könnt
ihr auch gerne die gleiche menge
backpulver noch dazu geben aber natron
lässt den tag aber wir sind besser
ausgehen dass jetzt alles kurz verbinden
jetzt kommen die flüssigen zutaten dazu
also die eier extrakt das hatte ich
vergessen ohne vanille geht natürlich
gar nichts dann etwas butter milch und
die flüssige butter und jetzt die
zutaten einfach nur kurz verrühren
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt der teig einfach in den
muffin vom rhein die habe ich bereits
mit papier förmchen belegt es geht am
besten mit einem eis funktionieren und
so werden sie im vorgeheizten backofen
bei 200 grad ober unterrichts dafür fünf
minuten gebacken
dann stelle ich auf 170 herunter und
wachsen noch mal etwa 20 minuten
[Musik]
die marken sind jetzt schon abgekühlt
und jetzt kann ich selber fühlen
ich zeige euch mal die zutaten für die
füllung dafür brauche ich etwa drei bis
vier bananen 50 gramm puderzucker etwas
vanille extrakt 400 milliliter sahne 500
gramm magerquark etwas an apart 50 km
schokostreusel und für die deko brauche
ich deko karotten jetzt nehmt ihr den
muffin und können zum beispiel einen
ausstecher verwenden oder einfach ein
messer und nimmt jetzt hier das innere
raus
und zwar sollte es so groß sein dass
eine banane rein passt also nicht die
ganze auf und durchmesser her und den
partner mich jetzt und hebt ihn auf das
heißt ich komme jetzt in der schüssel
und den rest können dass ein bisschen
raus löffeln so dass so ein bisschen
platz entsteht für die bande
der letzte jetzt kann ich die cupcakes
oder die muffins hier einfach mal liegen
lassen und die creme zu bereiten
dafür nehme ich zuerst einmal die sahne
und kann somit 4 telefon seiner park
steif schlagen
[Musik]
die sahne ist soweit jetzt kann ich in
einer separaten schüssel den quark
gemeinsam mit dem puderzucker verrühren
da kommt noch mal extra dazu
[Musik]
und noch etwas seiner partei augenmaß
abgemessen
[Musik]
hier kommen jetzt auch die sahne dazu
und die kann ich dann ganz vorsichtig
einrühren und jetzt noch die
schokostreusel mitreisen und jetzt nehme
ich eine banane und schneit die jetzt so
ab dass sie von der höhe her gut in die
muffins reinpasst wenn sie ein bisschen
drüber guckt nicht schlimm
[Musik]
und jetzt verteidigt die creme wo ein
bisschen hügel freue mich über den
muffins und es geht am besten mit ihnen
spritzbeutel gibt davon habe ich eine
große woche dran und dann kann ich dir
einfach darüber verteilt und ein
bisschen mit einer palette glatt
streichen
[Musik]
und nachdem glatt streichen dann einfach
hier in diese krümmel mischung tauchen
ich habe einfach die kuchen reste
zerkrümelt und wer's noch schokoladiger
möchte kann hier auch noch eine show
streusel dazu geben
[Musik]
und für die beko setze ich jetzt nur
noch diese kleinen märchen drauf die
kennt man ja normalerweise sind die aus
marzipan oder außen richtig fest und
zucker wo man sich fast im zahn raus
weist die hier sind jetzt aus weißer
schokolade also finde ich echt mega
lecker und entweder könnt ihr zwei so
rein stecken oder wenn sie
dreidimensional sein soll
einfach so zwei aneinander und dann
zusammen rein
die sind echt schön der moral also es
ist nicht so die ersten märchen die mir
richtig gut gefallen so wie ich war
schon in vielen städten
da und wenn ihr jetzt auch noch ein
bisschen creme üblich habe wie ich habe
aber auch noch ein bisschen von der
masse übrig dann könnt ihr das einfach
verrühren und zum beispiel in schicht-
oder löffel der vermachen paar bananen
noch rein schneiden oder ihr macht
einfach von anfang an ein bisschen
weniger creme zumal ich habe jetzt nicht
alles gebraucht oder übrigens einfach
damit sogar das aus
da ist das problemlos nur so mau gefühl
ja viel los
ich habe die klimaforschung nach spricht
ich mag halt die mischung aus quark und
sahne
so sieht es aus trocken okay ich hab es
bei dem löffel gegessen aber hoch hat
kann auch einfach rein und schön
schokolade und und die schokoraspeln wo
uns die knochen ich bin es damals in
martins sich die so trocken erich schmid
richtig so richtig und ich mag die
banane da drin weil es keine banale mag
kann auch kirschen zum beispiel
reinmachen oder zur etwa zeit auch
erdbeeren das schmeckt bestimmt auch
super lecker zum aufbruch mit erdbeeren
aber bitte erst zur erdbeerzeit und wenn
ihr das rezept nach machen möchtet dann
findet jetzt auf meinem blog nach salz -
blog.de untersteht alles für euch noch
mal ganz genau ich wünsche euch viel
spaß beim nachmachen ist ein
superschnelles rezept auch wenn ihr mal
wassersport haben jemanden zu besuch
erwartet wurde und innerhalb von
eineinhalb stunden oder so jemanden zum
besuch erwartet weil ich stand auch in
der gruppe war das war montag unterstand
meine freude kommt am donnerstag spontan
sowieso und ich dachte okay was hat
eigentlich jemand direkt vor der tür und
bin ich noch nicht wieder da sind macht
einfach nicht auf die schokolade ist
auch ins meinen es ist kein zucker ist
nur 1 100 sekunde ich kenne auch
schmeckt lecker und weiter möchten
gesund also klar wolf morath viel spaß
am essen guten appetit und bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]